-Welcome, welcome, welcome,
everybody.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
Well, guys, today is Earth Day.
Today is Earth Day.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Yeah, everyone is trying
to do their part.
As we speak,
CNN is properly disposing
of CNN+.
[ Laughter ]
In honor of Earth Day,
I saw that President Biden
visited Seattle
and signed an executive order
to safeguard old-growth forests.
That's great. Can we see
an old-growth forest?
[ Laughter and applause ]
Oh, look at that chest hair.
Yeah, that's nice.
Look at that chest hair.
-Ooh la la.
-[ French accent ] Oh, am I
sexy enough for you?
[ Laughter ]
Yeah. Yeah.
While Biden was in Seattle,
he also spoke about the need
for using clean energy
and he even demonstrated
how powerful windmills can be.
Watch this.
[ Whirring ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yeah.
Oh, there you go.
They are powerful.
Ahead of Earth Day,
Apple announced that it is using
more recycled materials
to make its products
than ever before.
Yeah, recycled iPhones.
It's weird when you turn on your
new iPhone and Siri says --
-I used to be a Shake Weight.
-Okay.
I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
Guys, the second weekend
of Coachella just kicked off
and I heard that,
since the first weekend,
COVID cases in the area
have gone up by 77%.
[ Oohs and ohs ]
Everyone there is like,
"I can't believe
this is happening
when we're doing everything
we're not supposed to do!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
Meanwhile, with all the news
about shifting mask guidelines,
it's time to play the game
that's sweeping the nation...
♪♪
[ Applause ]
This is the game where we pick
a random audience member
and guess if there's a stache
[ Laughter and applause ]
under their mask.
So please welcome tonight's
audience member, Kevin Sproul.
Kevin, where are you?
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
Nice to see you, Kevin.
Kevin, thank you for being
on "The Tonight Show."
Kevin, where are you from?
-San Diego.
That's all I can ask you.
[ Laughter ]
Alright, now, we have
to figure out if you've got
a stache under that mask.
Wait, hold on.
Quest, you go first.
You can ask him one question
and then you must
make your guess.
-Alright.
-Think hard.
You only get one.
-I got one.
-Okay. Kevin. Okay.
-Okay, so, at dinner,
how many napkins
are you likely to use?
[ Laughter ]
I'm actually an exceptionally
clean eater,
so I usually
only use one napkin.
-Mm.
Tricky.
[ Murmuring ]
[ Laughter ]
Mm.
-Are you going to guess now?
Or are you going to save it?
-Oh, okay.
I'll guess now.
I think he has a stache.
I think he's trying to trap me.
-Okay. Okay.
He said one napkin. Okay.
Higgins, your turn.
What's your question?
-Hmm.
[ Laughter ]
-San Diego, again?
-San Diego.
-San Diego, California?
-Indeed.
[ Laughter ]
-Got it.
That's my question.
-That almost counts
as a question.
That can't be your question.
Is San Diego in California
is the question.
-Is it in California?
[ Laughter ]
Does it take you, now,
the same amount of time
as it always has to shave?
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-Pff!
I'm going to say
no stache.
-Yeah!
-Yeah. Okay.
Okay. Okay. My turn.
-It's in California.
-Thank you.
No, that's not my question.
[ Laughter ]
Okay. Okay.
San Diego.
You look like
a clean-cut dude to me.
Alright, here's my question.
Do people mistake you for
Burt Reynolds
or Timothée Chalamet?
[ Laughter ]
-I would say the most I get is
the Buddha.
[ Laughter ]
-Ah!
-Buddha was cleanshaven.
Buddha is cleanshaven,
is what I think.
You say no stache.
-I say no stache.
-Quest?
-I say stache.
-You say stache.
-Yes.
-Gosh! I'm getting this vibe
of no stache.
I think he's a clean-cut dude.
I think no stache.
It's time to find out...
-...is there a stache
under that mask?
[ Drumroll ]
-Ah!
[ Rimshot ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
Oh.
That's not bad. Thank you, man.
I appreciate it.
Oh, wait, Kevin!
I'm sorry.
Thank you for playing.
Of course, here,
you've won a two-week supply
of Turtle Wax.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-There you go.
-Turtle Wax.
When you're here, you're family.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you for playing, bud.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Wow!
Stache.
[ Rimshot ]
-He knew. He knew.
-Yeah, looks good,
looks good, looks good.
Alright, anyways,
getting back to the news.
Well, guys, the Tony Awards
are coming up
and they just issued
a strict no-violence policy...
[ Laughter ]
...to potential ticket buyers.
That's right, the Tonys,
no violence.
No violence, yeah.
Because you can always tell
a fight's going to break out
at the Tonys
when people start snapping.
[ Snapping fingers ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ Hey, boy ♪
♪♪
I appreciate it.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Water?
-Oxygen?
-Some business news --
I read that the CEO of Old Navy
is stepping down.
Now, Old Navy's going to try on
a dozen new CEOs
before finding one that fits
and leaving the rest
on the floor.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's very interesting.
And, finally, this weekend,
two stunt pilots will attempt
the first ever plane swap.
This is where they're going
to fly close together,
go into a nosedive,
then jump into each other's
planes before landing.
[ Laughter and ohs ]
Yeah, it'll be the one time
the pilot
actually deserves applause
for landing the plane.
There you go.
[ Laughter and applause ]
We have a great show.